all right let's move to this so this
week the atlantic hosted a uh seminar at
the university of chicago called
disinformation and the erosion of
democracy where a whole bunch of
high-profile people in media and
politics to include obama apparently was
there um and they showed up to talk
about the dangers of disinformation
even though these are the purveyors of
disinformation
and this was a fact not lost on some in
the audience who were college kids
and during the q a portions they had the
chance to call the propagandist to task
in some really glorious video footage we
can't play all this but i want to play a
few a few a few clips here so first
here's a student
asking i think the first question that
comes to mind i mean you're having this
disinformation seminar
and you are the people who claim that
the hunter biden
laptop was disinformation turns out that
that claim was disinformation how do you
rectify all that so here's a student
asking an atlantic journalist about um
this problem thank you for doing this
really appreciate it i'm daniel schmidt
i'm a freshman at the university of
chicago my question is for miss
applebaum um so in 2020 you wrote those
who live outside the fox news bubble do
not of course need to learn any of this
stuff about hunter biden referring to
his laptop of curse a poll later after
that found that if voters knew about the
content of the laptop 16 percent of joe
biden voters would have acted
differently now of course we know a few
weeks ago the new york times confirmed
that the content is real do you think
the media acted inappropriately when
they instantly dismissed hunter biden's
laptop as russian disinformation and
what can we learn from that and ensuring
that what we label as this information
is truly this information and not
reality
my problem with hunter biden's laptop is
i think totally irrelevant i mean it's
not whether it's disinformation or i
mean i don't think the
hunter biden's um
business relationships have anything to
do with who should be president united
states so
i i didn't fi i don't find it to be
interesting i mean that that would be my
problem with the that as a as a major
news story
oh it's not it's not interesting it just
just doesn't interest me that's all i
don't find it interesting
is that is that how we're deciding now
what news is worthy to be printed
if it's if it's interesting or not to
you personally
subjectively
during a during a presidential campaign
we're making decisions based on what you
personally find interesting
and if you don't find it interesting
then not only are we not going to talk
about it but it's going to be banned
from social media
that's that's a great power i mean i'd
love to have that power just ban
everything from social media that i
don't find interesting which would be
like 99.9 of the stuff on it
um not interesting she says but that of
course is not
what they were saying two years ago they
were not saying that it's not
interesting they were saying that it's
false that it's uh that it's
disinformation
so the next day this happened a couple
days ago the next day jonah goldberg
who's the token conservative on the
panel
um
responded to this bit about the uh and
he's also someone by the way who said
that this was all disinformation and a
lie and hoax and everything and he
responded and has had his thoughts about
it let's listen to that
talk about a to c
they now think that if only the media
had told us about the laptop at the time
as the kid yesterday was suggesting
which i don't buy his ex you know theory
that trump would have won you know but
for the censoring of the new york post
trump would have won
and it's i think it's a preposterous
counterfactual
but it's also an it's impossible for me
to refute in the same way i cannot
refute that this bottle is keeping all
the polar bears away
right um i mean do you see any polar
bears right i cannot i cannot prove the
negative and um and this is just
it has now become can we lock the doors
just
it is it has been wrapped into
a much larger narrative
and
um and so when they hear disinformation
they say oh you mean like hunter laptop
which actually turned out to be true
it's actually interior it's sickening to
listen to these smarmy
keeping the polar bears away that's not
the point
jonah you know that's not the point
the point isn't isn't whether or not
it's true that it would have swayed the
election one way or another
look i i actually i
i myself am skeptical that the hunter
biden laptop story would have swayed the
election
could have
um i'm skeptical that what i i said that
at the time when this when this story
came out and conservatives and and
right-wing media were hammering on the
hunter biden laptop thing right as we
were heading into the election
and uh now i didn't say that it's
disinformation and it should be banned
from social media i said like i it's
true but
i don't think that this is the best
closing argument i don't think the best
closing argument against biden is that
his son is a scumbag and yeah you can
draw the connection between his son and
biden and you can draw these connections
and they are connected but that's a it's
a
it's if you want a political scandal to
land it has to be pretty simple and easy
to explain
and to connect the dots between hunter
biden's laptop and joe biden himself
that takes a couple more moves and it
just it's it's um
it's a harder case to make especially in
the closing weeks of a campaign you want
to go things that are much simpler and
more to the point about joe biden
himself because a lot of people they're
going to hear about
hunter's laptop well turns out a lot of
people didn't hear about it because it
was censored by the media but i think a
lot of people would hear about it and
say well yeah i don't care what's up to
do with joe biden yeah his son his grown
son is a scumbag okay
um
again there is a connection there but
drawing the getting people to see the
connection
is a different matter it's not it's not
it's not the same thing right um i think
the stronger argument and the closing
argument against biden all along should
be about him and how incompetent he is
and also
his age and i know that his age came up
a lot but i think that should have been
the headline that should have been the
number one thing
hammering on the entire time this man is
losing his mind he's not fit for office
he's 78 years old he's got he's seen
aliens dementia yeah it was talked about
plenty but in my mind that's the number
one most salient thing in the election
to bring up okay um
but
that's that's academic that's that's
irrelevant
the fact is we don't know whether it
would have swayed the election because
it was censored
and all that matters whether or not it
would have or or wouldn't have not the
point
the point is
that the powers that be in the culture
the media
big tech they thought that it would
which is why they censored it
so this was an attempt to rig and sway
the election
not just an attempt it was they were
rigging
and they were rigging the election
that's it
now how do you quantify
the the effect that it had when you you
can't because you're speaking in in the
in theoretical and theoretical terms to
know for sure you have to go back in
time and do it all over again but
without without censoring that material
we can't do that so we can only speak
theoretically but this was a rigging of
the election that happened because big
tech and the media they thought
that this could be damning enough to
convince people to vote to either just
not vote for biden at all or to actually
vote for trump
and they were having flashbacks to the
email scandal with hillary clinton in
2016 which absolutely did
absolutely was one of the deciding
factors and
as well it ought to have been
leading to her losing and trump winning
so they were having flashbacks to that
and they said we cannot we can't let
this happen again
and so we're going to censor this
material
jonah goldberg is missing the point on
purpose
talking about in theory well what would
have happened that's not it they thought
that it would and they tried to censor
it and they did censor it because of
that
and that's the point
and it is it is
uh
it should infuriate you especially if
you pretend to care so much about
democracy and you're always accusing
trump and
the far right of waging an assault on
democracy
well how is this not an assault on
democracy
when there is
factual
and relevant
information about a political candidate
in a presidential election
that is kept from public view
because of how it might
sway them
how is that not an assault on democracy
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated